voilà ce faire le sma temps joue aux
braves de voir un gars mais c'est ton
affaire mais qui se passe pendant que tu
es une femme en otage avec un bébé dans
maison ceux ci n'accepte toit permanent
vous êtes une des comédiennes les plus
en vue au québec télévision cinéma
théâtre des entrevues comme celle ci
comment faites vous pour ne pas vous
perdre dans tout ça je ne me perds pas
parce que c'est ma passion
alors plus j'exerce ce métier plus je
tombe en amour avec lui c'est sûr qu'on
a on comme dans une relation amoureuse
d'ailleurs c'est ma plus durable mais on
a des hauts et des bas mais j'embrasse
même ses défauts et je laime
profondément puis me sollicite de
manière tellement différente sur des
projets il est des projets qui appelle
deux mois différentes facettes donc
voilà on se choisit constamment j'espère
que ça se ressente c'est notre vision
ce métier parfois il vous a brisé le
camp oui ça arrive ça arrive
oh oui farhi mais évidemment c'est un
métier de désir parfois on ne désire -
et puis c'est important mais je pense
que ce travail d'une vie de faire en
sorte que la qualité d'être de ce conte
et ne se résume pas à ce qu'on fait mais
en même temps c'est difficile de tracer
la ligne caen quand chaque parcelle de
soi est sollicité pour un rouge
vous m'avez beaucoup ému dans les
lettres
c'est gentil et d'ailleurs après la
première vous avez tellement émue vous
que vous avez pleuré dire que ce
pansement non mais il ya plusieurs
choses premièrement ce phénomène là me
fascine j'aimerais celles étudiées un
jour j'ai pas du tout aux rapports
troubles au jeu il est très très heureux
donc je confonds jamais les émotions du
personnage avec les miennes par contre
ces émotions l'autre traverse
physiquement notre corps pour vrai serez
l'être par exemple je travaillais la
colère et mon corps vraiment réagi j'ai
été suivie par un métier pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui m'arrivait qui sait
des symptômes de la colère
cette colère là n'était pas la mienne
cette espèce de mon personnage mais
c'est pourtant mon corps qui la portait
et ça ça me je trouve ça tellement beau
et facile et je pense que premièrement
c'était un grand défi
j'ai travaillé sur ce projet là depuis
deux ans avec serge denoncourt et et
donc qu'il y avait probablement leur
fallait un chemin et vous du genre un
peu parce que vous avez aussi
interpréter le rôle de rock semble dans
cyrano de bergerac ici même à vous en
être très fiers et vous avez déjà dit
que vous avez vu plus d'une centaine de
fois le cyrano de bergerac avec gérard
depardieu est ce qu'un petit côté
obsessif dans les oeuvres que vous aimez
je pense que c'est le propre de la
plupart des artistes d'avoir une
certaine si une certaine obsession il
faut il faut est insatiable je pense
pour pour faire ce métier là il faut
avoir une curiosité qui sera jamais tout
à fait assouvie donc oui quand je suis
fasciné par quelque chose qui arrive
souvent que je revisite l'oeuvre en
question que je creuse le sillon plus
profondément parce que parce que c'est
la seule façon je pense d'apprendre
d'avancé puis puisque piqué mais c'est
une grande affaire alors quand on aime
quelque chose on s'en lasse pas à
l'instance par votre ami monia chokri et
au festival de cannes avec son film la
femme de mon frère mais on a fait un
petit fils time to tal ar oui elle est
bien rendu faisait beau la marina était
belle anne élisabeth bossé et monia
s'apprête à vivre des grandes grandes
choses ce qui est très spécial c'est
'qui anne-élisabeth bossé
évelyne brochu sophie cadieux voudrait
que toute une génération de comédienne
qui vont de l'avant
comment vous la voyez justement cette
génération là qui prend vraiment sa
place et et qui ne jouent pas justement
les les comédiennes de service mais qui
ont une plaie pouvoir sur la production
mais je pense qu'on est les airs et les
héritières des générations qui nous ont
précédés et qui nous ont ouvert beaucoup
de portes
oui je les actrices que vous avez nommés
mais il y en a d'autres aussi
je nous trouve assez serré on parle
beaucoup de rivalité féminine mais moi
je constate vraiment l' inverse est déjà
tellement d'adversité au sein de ce
métier là que je pense qu'on a compris
que s'il fallait en plus être des
rivales les unes pour les autres baies à
ce moment là ça serait la jungle puis on
n'a pas envie que notre métier soso donc
on se nourrit énormément les unes des
autres on s'admire on se dit on s'aime
on s'en cache pop il en est fier voilà
magalie lépine blondeau
merci merci à vous